well first of all thank you Mike for the
invitation to to be here and and I I
just want to actually pick up more or
less exactly where nike finished and
talk make her just a few comments about
energy innovation I think we all
recognize that if we're going to have
any chance of solving these enormously
challenging climate problems it's going
to be through innovations to bring the
cost down of low-cost alternatives to
fossil fuel and I would argue that
probably our biggest challenge certainly
in this country but I think this is a
more general issue is to design a system
of institutions the energy innovation
system that has a much more that is much
more effective at mobilizing America's
innovation resources toward the goal of
cost reduction of low-carbon
technologies than the one we have today
now of course there's no silver bullet
will need wind and solar and geothermal
and carbon capture and storage and
electricity storage and a great deal a
huge amount of course of energy
efficiency measures but I've been asked
to talk specifically about a nuclear so
let me say a couple of points about that
but maybe before I do you know we we
those of us who work in these areas get
very familiar with these charts and
lines on a chart don't always capture
the real scale of of the challenge and
so let me you many of you probably seen
this chart this is every each small
square on that chart is ten million tons
of per year of carbon dioxide and
there's 726 little squares on that chart
even for the the three degrees scenario
which most people would consider
inadequate we in the US if we set our
goals the same as everybody else's which
many would also say is an inadequate
task but even for the three degrees
scenario where you have the sort of
weakest view of global equity we would
have to remove seventy percent of those
squares and we would have to do it as
someone said our chairman said I think
in his opening remarks we'd have to do
it over this is I should say by the year
2050 a period during which we can expect
even our economy to double in size
assuming a relatively modest two percent
per capita growth rate between now and
then so it's a you know this is we have
to think about the scale here's another
view of scale ah let's just imagine do a
thought experiment all of the coal we
consumed in the United States today in a
single year in our coal-fired power
plants which account these days for
about 35 little over 30 maybe thirty
seven percent of our electricity if we
put all that coal on a single train and
that train went to all of the several
hundred coal-fired power plants to
deliver the coal that those plants need
during the course of the year that train
would be 83,000 miles long and in order
even to achieve the seventy percent
reduction goal by 2050 effectively we
have to reduce eliminate that
eighty-three thousand mile coltrane
that's the that's the scale of the task
now you know people are very optimistic
of course about natural gas and by the
way if all of that coal were to be
replaced by natural gas total emissions
would decline in the US by about twenty
percent that's a very significant
decline but of course not even a third
of
would be needed even in this less
aggressive scenario of seventy percent
reduction by mid-century so my question
is can we do this without nuclear well
we can't prove in a mathematical sense
the answer to that question but I think
it is a matter of basic common sense
that when you have a very difficult task
like this the more options that are
available the more likely you are to
succeed and if any option is taken off
the table the chances of failing will
increase and this is especially true in
the case of in this case because no two
low-carbon options are alike solar wind
geothermal and nuclear and others each
have their own strengths and weaknesses
and given the enormously varied a nature
of the energy system and the certainty
that there will be surprises over the
next few decades just think of the
surprises we've had over the last five
years we will have surprises in energy
and that adds to the value of diversity
in our energy portfolio now the are
there's a I think probably many of us in
the room of familiar with the debate
about nuclear the advantages and
disadvantages and it's all been very
extensively discussed here i just want
to mention a couple of aspects that I
think may not be fully appreciated even
now despite the extensive debate on
these issues one is the extreme
compactness of nuclear systems for
example that same thought experiment
that produced the 83,000 mile-long coal
train would yield a one-mile-long
nuclear train that's the amount of space
on a train delivering nuclear fuel that
would be required to fuel our 100
nuclear power plants generating about 20
% of the country's electricity in the
course of a year the second aspect is
the ability of nuclear programs to scale
up quickly now this whole debate is
about rapid scale-up of low-carbon
energy if we can't scale up rapidly
we're not going to come close to
achieving these goals we want rapid
scale up in solar and wind and and all
of the other low carbon sources in fact
historically and this may come as a
surprise it actually came as a bit of a
surprise to me the let me just skip to
this chart historically arm the its
nuclear energy that has been by far the
most rapid rapidly scaling low-carbon
energy source um this shows the amount
of carbon mitigation that was achieved
in countries like Sweden and France and
Belgium during the peak decades of
nuclear installation in the 1970s and
80s a time when nobody was actually
talking or very few people were talking
about low carbon or carbon mitigation
but actually during that period the rate
of addition of low-carbon in this case
kilowatt hours of electricity per capita
because that's the key metric here low
carbon electricity per capita that it
was far more rapid uh then we've been
able to achieve in even top of the table
renewable countries like Denmark and and
and spain in the last decade or so with
their very aggressive deployment of
solar and wind and in Germany which of
course is now phasing out its nuclear
plants low carbon kilowatt hours were
added when those plants were being
phased in twice as fast as has resulted
from the heavy German investment in wind
and solar over
last decade of course that's all in the
past and perhaps the pace of solar and
wind deployment will accelerate in the
future we hope it will and certainly the
cost reductions that we've seen will
suggest Sidhu suggests some acceleration
although it's worth noting that the very
aggressive subsidy policies that have
driven renewables growth in in countries
like Germany and Spain probably aren't
sustainable and may in fact have run
their course ok so if nuclear is to play
a significant role beyond its current
contribution to low-carbon or carbon
mitigation the magnitude of this climate
challenge is such that the global
nuclear contribution would probably need
to increase by a factor of two or three
by mid-century if nuclear is to play
more than a rather minor role in future
climate mitigation efforts it's true
that there are ambitious plans for
nuclear expansion in some countries
China most notably but if you add up all
those plans that countries say that
they're going to do with nuclear and
also account for the expected retirement
of much of the existing nuclear plant
fleet because they're getting old and
will soon reach or at some point will
reach their end of life the actual
nuclear role are in carbon mitigation
under current plans business if you like
business as usual is likely to grow only
pretty slowly during the coming decades
and may even start to decline so how to
close the gap between needs and plans
well our innovation innovation are
probably most importantly our innovation
in governance to ensure broad adherence
to the principles of safe and and secure
nuclear
erations which was so clearly not
present in in Japan and to reassure the
public that nuclear energy can be used
safely innovations in people that's
education and training to provide the
capabilities for expansion in this area
but also very likely innovations in
technology and here I just want to close
by mentioning a few elements of a
strategy for nuclear innovation one will
involve placing more reliance on passive
safety mechanisms in nuclear plant
design the new generation of light water
reactors has moved in this direction but
more advanced designs go much further
toward the goal of walk away safety it
doesn't seem too far-fetched to
speculate that that goal walk away
safety will become a requirement for all
nuclear power reactors 30 or 50 years
from now another key goal is to reduce
nuclear cycle times which have become
almost pathologically long in the US and
elsewhere and which are adding costs and
reducing flexibility and exposing
investors to greater risk certainly
progress will require regulatory reform
but there are also opportunities for
technologically driven cycle time
reductions for example dramatic
improvements in modeling and simulation
capabilities new construction methods
promising to shorten project lead times
small modular reactors we've heard a lot
about those whose hope for benefits also
include reductions in capital at risk
faster learning cycles and better
matching with small power grids the
grids themselves are on the verge of
dramatic change over the next two
decades we are likely to see changes in
the electric power grid in this country
and other countries
that are more far-reaching than anything
we have seen over the last several
decades and the challenge for nuclear
and other generating technologies is to
work out how to meet rapidly varying
electrical loads are affordably and
reliably with hybrid low-carbon power
systems consisting mainly of
dispatchable nuclear and non
dispatchable renewables and there are
some very interesting ideas here about
hybrid nuclear technologies that we can
perhaps discuss in later maybe we'll see
other possibilities for example lifetime
fueling of reactor cores the so-called
nuclear battery concept and integrated
power plant waste disposal systems with
spent fuel never actually leaving the
boundary of the nuclear power plants but
disposed of directly in modular deep
boreholes several miles below the
earth's surface in the stable dry
bedrock that under underlies most large
areas of most countries advances in
computational power new tools for
material synthesis may one day make it
possible to design and build radiation
resistant materials from the ground up
atom by atom and create ultra-secure
nuclear waste materials with lifetimes
of tens of thousands of years now we can
imagine all of these things today by the
way there are many other things that we
can't imagine that on a several decade
timescale we may or some of the younger
ones of you may see arm but nobody knows
which of these will actually emerge the
one thing we do know the one thing we do
know is the nuclear power plants of the
year 2100 will bear about as much
similarity to the workhorse light water
reactors of today as my car there's
similarity to a 1914
Model T Ford ah and the final point I
want to make is that the leaders of
these innovations and I've just really
scratched the surface they aren't going
to be people like me they're going to be
the outstanding young engineers and
scientists who are today populating
despite the events of the last few years
today populating nuclear engineering
programs around this country in growing
numbers 30 years ago after three mile
island after Chernobyl many of the
smartest nuclear engineers left the
field and a lot more chose not to enter
it and that was of course because of the
uncertain outlook for the nuclear
industry at the time but it was also
because the industry itself became very
cautious and inward looking and very
reluctant to change and for a dynamic
young engineer that didn't seem like the
future but today as I look at the young
nuclear engineers in my department at
MIT and elsewhere it feels like a
somewhat different time these people
these young people understand that
without nuclear were probably cooked
almost literally they want to do
something about climate change and they
see nuclear as one part of the solution
and they see great engineering
challenges in designing new nuclear
power systems that are safer than
today's technologies and that are also
economically competitive and the deliver
waste and security benefits too and
they're willing to invest the serious
time and effort needed to learn and
master the new technologies they
understand that this isn't this isn't
innovating through iphone apps they
understand that this is a multi-year
many decade investment in many cases and
in some cases they're willing to take
the entrepreneurial risks needed to
reduce these technologies to practice so
I let me finish just by observing that
the pundits the pundits at the
economist and others like to make snappy
pronouncements about nuclear energy and
unfortunately my slide that I had
showing that many of you some of you may
remember the cover of The Economist's
that said nuclear energy the dream that
failed well the thought I'd like to I
that the thought I'd like to leave you
with is that below the radar in fact
there's more new thinking and ferment in
the nuclear field than I've seen in a
very long time and that the era of
nuclear innovation may actually just
beginning started so thank you